-The game is simple.
One at a time, while maintaining
the utmost composure,
we will, very slowly,
turn our heads,
look in to the camera, and do
the tiniest head-nod possible.
-Yes.
-Whoever does
the tinier nod wins.
And you're not allowed to laugh.
Kate, since you're my guest...
-I didn't know that part.
-...you'll be turning first.
Are you ready for this?
This is your camera over there.
-Yeah.
-Okay, good. You ready?
-Okay.
-Okay, they're ready.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Roots?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's hard. That is hard.
-You are so good.
-Wow.
-No, that was really good.
It was really good.
All right,
that was a very tiny nod.
All right, it's my turn.
-Okay.
-However, I'd like to take
a moment here.
[ Clears throat ]
Whew. Okay.
Now, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, we got --
that is not easy.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-We have to up the stakes
a little bit here.
All right, round two. Round two.
Are you guys ready for
round two?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You must turn your head
even more slowly,
look into the camera.
You have to flare
your nostrils twice...
[ Laughter ]
...and then do a tiny nod.
I mean, that is -- this is --
it's very important stuff
right here.
Kate, are you ready for this?
Uh-huh.
-Round two. This is round two.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-Two nostril flares.
-Got it. Okay.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Perfect nostril flare.
-That's tough.
-Wow, that was impressive.
And we -- you -- we've never
played this before, right?
Okay. Just so we know.
We're not professionals.
-I played it in a dream once.
-Yeah. Okay, here we go.
-All right.
-All right. I'm up.
Here we go.
-Whew, okay.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
-Round three.
-Whoa.
The sound of someone saying
"round three"
means it is time
for round three.
[ Laughter ]
Kate, you must now, somehow,
turn your head ever more slowly,
then look into the camera
and make the tiniest sound
you could possibly make.
-Okay.
-And then nod.
Here we go.
This is the last
and final round.
Winner takes all.
Are you ready for this?
-I'm scared but yes.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-This is the best game
we've ever played.
-The best game I have ever seen
in my whole life.
-All right, here we go.
I can't top that,
but I will give it a try.
Here we go. Roots?
-Bring it home, J. Come on.
-All right.
Get my background music.
Come on, roots.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Uh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner is Kate McKinnon.
Come on!
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You got me.
Kate McKinnon.